nuki has a lot of theories and a lot of
ideas that he's probably he's gonna do
if hopefully season two I do want to
break down this finale with you because
I had so many questions afterwards it
did kind of feel like Carrie but with a
supernatural twist what did you guys
make of the finale I loved it I thought
it was hilarious
yeah I know right so it's I feel like
it's exactly what it should happen
because kind of it the whole element and
the whole kind of feel of this story is
so kind of quick like quick on speed and
very fast paced very funny kind of humor
that like everything seems to be going
one way and suddenly it starts to change
and fun so I finally she feels like
she's becoming friends with everybody
and finally having a place in her life
and suddenly she blows someone's head up
that's one of the biggest things that
could possibly happen towards the end
and that's exactly the way it should go
it's almost it's it's no it's not funny
has this weird dark humor in it that's
just it's just unexplainably like if
this is why how did this happen no type
thing and I feel like that's just the
perfect way to end a series when you
watch it in the context of the series I
think it is such a beautiful little
photo put on top of things cuz it's just
you finally think that she has some
semblance of control over herself and
things are finally going right and yeah
you're so happy for her and just to have
him to be publicly outed like that you
don't wish that on anyone I don't want
to say anyone deserves to have their
head blown up but I think it really
gives a nice set up if
to progress forward shut so do we think
he's he's just not okay like there's no
room for him and sees them to you know
[Laughter]
we will see if there's any other avenues
yeah they could finally understand how
lonely my dad must've helped well let's
talk about why or how this happened
because she sounds like I get what my
dad felt so lonely now as this figure
sort of approaches her
what was that meant to mean do we know
who that guy is
I don't know for you I have a theory
what's your theory my theory is that
it's Stan Lee from the future hahaha I
don't know but like I just like I feel
bugging Jonathan about him like what if
it's Stan Lee the future yeah I feel
like Jonathan's so figuring it out yeah
I think he has a lot of theories and a
lot of ideas that he's probably he's
gonna do if hopefully season two
yes yes season - yeah he's told us kind
of you're some theories and then halfway
through he says that may not happen then
you're like well okay so no no none of
us knows I don't think you've been
Jonathan he's keeping it secret
yes should I be your friend they should
be afraid
let's begin she says should I be afraid
and this person says they should be
afraid let's begin who is who is family
are the soft people in general they
should be afraid yeah who don't have
superpowers and it's not you should be
afraid it's because you have powers
let's begin sort of uh we're gonna start
training with the superpowers possibly
maybe aren't you worried I'm being
followed
no one's following me Stan it's all in
my head
well because Stanley's very into the
superpowers he knows all of this where
do you guys see that friendship
relationship going those are obviously
already some tension that's built up
through the through the first season
with Stanley and Sidney like especially
near the end where they have like us
sort of falling out and I think that
that's something that gets sort of
resolved by the end of it but I think
there's still something there and
someone else training or whatever he
does with Sidney I think he won't really
appreciate that personally you know
there's no jealousy absolutely I think
so I think Stanley is gonna have to
fight so what where does Dena
where does Dena fit into all of this do
you think she got a whole thing whole
thing to figure out on that what
happened yeah then also I just ran off
so I don't know okay okay what I really
just would want for Dena
anyway is just for her to understand
that she doesn't have to please everyone
to please herself because you can really
see it in season one she's so giving and
so loving and like she's like loves Brad
also is like no she's hurting Sid so she
goes back to apologize like she really
isn't and which is really cool because
in most stories you know girl gets the
guy and then leaves her best friend sure
but she kind of goes back so what I
really want for her is to just allow
herself to be happy with herself first
and make sure that that's coming from
her and not from her what would you like
to see in a season two if it were up to
you I'd like to see me a season two I'd
like to know what her superpower is like
what it all means right now like who a
common yeah like the backs of it I want
some more lower yeah that's a good idea
tell the writers that yeah we could get
that answer
- maybe I think so dear diary go
yourself the team behind stranger things
and the end of the effing world are
behind this show so what was that like
for you guys and are you expecting any
sort of comparisons or anything like
that I think we've got plenty of
comparisons already yeah I think
people's like expectations are very
clear because of who's behind it and
what we really wanted to create was
something unique with a lot of elements
that you've seen before and hopefully
we've accomplished that but yeah I'd say
we were I was just like excited to see
that such amazing people were working
behind it because as Sophia said the
script was really interesting and being
able to trust everyone behind it is
really nice and also working with people
who have worked with our friends before
like Finn obviously on stranger things
and working with Sean ladies I do feel
like it's a little bit different from
stranger things - sure it's a unique
story besides the fact there is a girl
with superpowers I feel like that's
actually the only comparison they're
very different from eleven very
different it's a her learning how to
deal with these superpowers when with
the whole loving thing things she
superpowers is all she knows and she
doesn't have a normal life this is it's
kind of like almost the reverse you know
Sydney has a normal life and suddenly it
starts getting out of control
and it that's just a whole different
story
yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]